hi I'm Erik Bosse and Jumanji welcome to
the jungle has been this year's surprise
box office beasts weighing the rock
Johnson Kevin Hart Jack Black Karen
Gillan and Nick Jonas starred in a solid
action adventure with some interesting
subtle nod to the original Robin
Williams movie and other classic films
so I'm gonna point out all the cool
stuff you might have missed and of
course spoiler warning if you haven't
seen the new Jumanji or the first
Jumanji is weird to think that there's a
Jumanji cinematic universe now but
that's what movies are in 2018 let's
start with the opening image the first
shot shows the original Jumanji game
board buried in the sand on the beach in
the year 1996 which is a direct callback
to the closing shot of the original film
where after the kids toss the game in a
river it washed up on a beach found by
girls speaking French I guess after some
poor French coastal city was nearly
flattened by rhinos as girls were like
oh wow I think suck that thing back to
America where it shows up on the same
New Hampshire town one year after the
events of the revised Jumanji timeline
and yes revised Jumanji timeline is as
weird for me to say as it is for you to
hear and yes you may have noticed the
name of this school where the kids go to
in the present-day Brantford High School
Brantford was of course the name of the
New Hampshire town where the first movie
was set now stepping back for a second
I'll admit that when this film was
announced and when I saw the trailer I
couldn't help but wonder is this really
a Jumanji movie or was it just a great
adventure story about kids sucked into a
jungle video game that some studio exec
was like hey with a few tweaks we could
market this is a Jumanji movie and use
that 90s nostalgia sell more tickets
yeah I'm evil but this is also my job I
have kids don't judge me I don't like to
think too hard about how film sausage
gets made or how any sausage gets named
gross but the producers of the film did
promise it would be an homage to Robin
Williams's story
for example halfway through the movie
may have noticed how steep Plains
hideout home includes a sign reading
Allen Parrish was here with seaplanes
saying he was a man who built this place
Alan Parrish was of course the name of
Robin Williams's character who is
trapped in the game board's jungle for
26 years before what Kirsten Dunstan a
little monkey boy eventually finished
the game he started so this makes things
a little confusing the Jumanji of this
movie is a video game so does this mean
Alan was in that video game too just to
clear this up in the opening scene of
this sequel after 1996
Alex refuses to play the board game
because it's like lame Jumanji
transforms to evolve
with the popular gaming technology of
the time in order to better lure victims
in to play it in the 60s flashback to
the original movie it's a board game
with all the steps of the game operating
by the rules of board game with dice
being rolled and game pieces moving
along a game board but in the 90s
Jumanji evolves into a 90s era style
video game with players taken on avatars
with different strengths and weaknesses
the villains name is Van Pelt the same
name is the old timey bounty hunter in
the original Van Pelt's has evolved
along with the world of the game from a
classic jungle myth character into a
stereotypical power-hungry villain from
a video game actually there was gonna be
an alternate ending for this movie
showing Jumanji popping up on everyone's
phones as a mobile game as this game
evolves into a new age of technology but
I suppose Jumanji secret evil agenda
might have just been a little too dark
for a fun adventure movie but this
darkness could live on where it belongs
now there are two other fun details that
link this movie back to the original
Jumanji board game that we'll talk about
later moving on it's interesting how
these opening scenes in the school
foreshadow the adventure that's to come
first notice the school's mascot is a
Jaguar a hint of the Jaguar statue that
they need to get to later and the Jaguar
its van pelt uses to pursue and attack
them also when the four kids sit in the
office for detention later there's a
total of five chairs leaving one seat
empty this first shadow is the fifth
member of the team Alex as seaplanes
still waiting to join up with them
meanwhile you may have caught mark Evan
Jackson as the principal using some
choice words with video game tones you
get one life and choose your weapon and
one more fun detail I got here fridges
Jersey is number 94 which was Dwayne
Johnson's number when he played football
at the University of Miami moving on as
they go inside the game notice how each
avatar identity features some fun visual
details Johnson as dr. smolder brave
Stone is largely making fun of himself
his the Zeke and bald head even refers
to himself in the third person at some
point just like the Rocky's to do the
rock does not need the rock does not
walk but the rock says this now before I
get to that second miserable reference
the rock made to his wrestling days just
a quick thank you to our sponsor
Alliance heroes of this fire we couldn't
made this video without them Alliance
here's to the spire is breaking into the
top mobile charts you gotta check it out
it has almost 400 unique heroes even
combined in over 10,000 different ways
in the battlefield I'd love this
the two coolest game modes are fighting
to the death against crazy giant bosses
as we live in all RPG games or to battle
real people even your best friends in
PvP mode not to mention the really
massive combat so you can fight between
guilds which are amazing look I can talk
to you about Alliance for hours but go
see for yourself you won't regret it you
can actually download alliance with my
links below and get a massive bonus of
50,000 gold and 50 gems right now what
look Jumanji doesn't have to be the only
game you care about as soon as this
video's done get on this back to the
rocks subtle self references in Jumanji
later on when fighting a bunch of Van
Pelt's guys he takes down one of them
with his classic rock bottom move no
this is something the rock does in
pretty much every movie Johnson also
mentioned classic Harrison Ford heroes
like Indiana Jones as inspiration for
brave stone with the weathered earth
tones of his costume designed to reflect
Indies get to a few other indie
references later but he also singled out
his low-hanging belt and machete is a
nod to Han Solo whose blaster holster
hangs a similar way Ruby roundhouse
meanwhile is largely a take on Lara
Croft
Martha even points out how impractical
or relatively bare wardrobe is for a
jungle environment Kevin Hart as Mouse
Finbar has Cape listed as his number one
weakness a totally random detail that
sets up when the funniest physical gags
of the whole film it's all good
and if you look closely his shirt
includes a patch now in a slice of cake
with a slash through it warning him not
to eat it by the way the Baker who gives
them these rations is played by actor
William Tokarski whom you might know is
the creepy murderer from that Adult Swim
too many cooks short that came out a few
years ago it's just really unnerving to
see this guy show up in the background
and then Jack Black as Bethany's avatar
has an interesting name Shellie Kay
Sheldon Oberon now in classic literature
Oberon is the king of fairies most
famously known from Shakespeare's A
Midsummer Night's Dream that play was a
comedy about for young people two men
two women who get lost in a magical
wilderness where most of the last come
from mistaken identity I would say
there's definitely a parallel here with
this movie specifically Jack Black's
character as the pretty girl stuck in
the body of an overweight man in his 40s
midway through the movie the group
realizes the missing piece of the map
they've been seeking is actually a
missing game piece which takes the form
of this elephant token you
may remember the elephant was Alan
parish's game piece in the first movie
so it must correspond to whomever the
player won is Alan was the first to roll
the dice in the first movie and Alex is
the first to play in this one
when Alex leads them through the booby
trap tunnel all these traps correspond
to dangers encountered by Indiana Jones
actually the director of this movie was
Jake Kasdan son of Larry Kasdan the
legendary screenwriter who wrote Raiders
of the Lost Ark so for example arrows
fly out at them when they cross into the
light just like they did at Indy in the
Raiders temple they all have to freeze
as razors spin out inches in front of
them just like the first trial Indy
faces in the Grail temple in the Last
Crusade they have to cross over a pit of
deadly crocodiles similar to the one
Indy almost falls into in the Temple of
Doom and they traverse his pit with a
narrow plank kind of like the pathway
Indy crosses in the leap of faith scene
in the Last Crusade and then of course
later when Martha /ruby ground house go
to retrieve the stone it's surrounded by
a pit of snakes designed to target her
weakness of venom it also votes that
classic huge snake pit scene at Indy
finds himself in and Raiders lastly
after Spenser / brave stone successfully
returns a stone to the eye of the Jaguar
and shouts Jumanji we get this overhead
shot of the jungle transforming and the
map is the same exact design of the
interlocking pathways of the original
Jumanji game board those are all the
interesting details I know it it's but a
question for you guys do you think
Jumanji welcome to the jungle needed to
be a Jumanji sequel could it have worked
as its own non Jumanji adventure story
about just kids sucked into a video game
with interesting funny opposing avatars
look I really like this movie I didn't
mind all the little nods to the original
Jumanji but this movie did kind of make
me miss the 90s growing up with movies
that weren't necessarily sequels or
parts of cinematic universes like I know
the original Jumanji wasn't totally
original was based on a children's book
but I didn't know that as a kid I was
like oh look at a cool new Robin
Williams movie now it's like the
studio's think we won't watch movies
unless some semi known brand name is
slapped in front of the movie which is
silly we didn't need that with Toy Story
in the 90s a movie's so great in
original and inspired an entire
cinematic universe of three sequels
anyway I want to know what your thoughts
on this are so comment down below and
tweet me directly at Els and follow new
rockstars on Twitter for more updates on
our videos and like and subscribe to new
rock stars for all the details you
missed and all the movies
love Star Wars Pixar movies Thor and all
the Avengers films and if you really
want to help us grow as a channel you
can contribute to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our donors by the way
especially Kelly hopper
you're the best Kells thanks for
watching guys bye
[Music]